have you ever wondered what made the
loudest sound on Earth
[Applause]
to put things in perspective let's start
small
breathing is around 10 decibels light
rain comes in at 40 decibels you get 70
from a vacuum cleaner 90 from a blender
and a live rock band will produce around
120.
the decibel scale measures noise
logarithmically
for our non-mathematicians when a sound
increases from 10 decibels to 20
decibels it becomes 10 times more
powerful going from 20 decibels to 30
increases the power by 10 times again
once you get into the 150 decibel range
the sound becomes powerful enough to
rupture eardrums so you should stand
well clear of a starting pistol at 140
decibels or a rocket launch of 180. and
at 194 decibels sound waves become shock
waves which can destroy nearby buildings
but that's nothing compared to what
happened on the 27th of August 1883. on
the Indonesian island of Krakatoa a
volcanic eruption produced what
scientists believe to be the loudest
sound recorded in human history as an
estimated 310 decibels it was reportedly
heard in more than 50 different
locations and the sound wave traveled
three and a half times around the planet
for as many as five days after the
explosion weather stations observed an
unprecedented spike in pressure
recurring roughly every 34 hours as it
circled the globe it caused deadly
tsunamis as far as Hawaii and South
America major drops in temperature in
the Northern Hemisphere and deeply
tinted sunsets in the West some
scientists have theorized that Edvard
monks the screen depicts those vibrant
orange Skies nothing in recorded history
has ever come close
foreign